hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week where you'll watch me try to
not burp during this video after
drinking carbonated water to make it so
I can talk to you hey this week we're
talking about
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.3 use multi-factor
authentication for local and network
access to privileged accounts and for
network access to non-privileged
accounts let's find out
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to figure out all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp171 compliance stuff on
top of an already colossal workload well
I've got great news for you you found
your home here at on-call compliance
Solutions where we can help you
transform into your company's con-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.3 use multi-factor
authentication for local and network
access to privileged accounts and for
network access to non-provised accounts
yes this is the one it creates the big
giant Nightmare and everybody hates it
but guess what
it also happens to be the one control
that will save your tokis right because
ultimately at the end of the day
multi-factor authentication is probably
the greatest invention for uh you know
network security and just generally
information security that's come around
in the last I don't know how many years
so there's a big challenge control a lot
of people have trouble with this one
from a cultural perspective to make
people do MFA for everything that
touches Cy is a big deal for some people
okay after years of working with clients
on this here's what I can tell you
if you have network access as an example
a map network drive you're going to need
MFA to access that data Maybe on
computer sign on however you need to do
it same with anything others any any
other system which contains cui you have
to have MFA your email if your email is
Office 365 GCC hi MFA better be turned
on okay if you've got an accounting
system and it's got It's got accounting
data that includes cui you better have
MFA to sign into it all right however
you'll notice that MFA is not required
for local standard user access a lot of
people miss this and make their lives a
whole lot harder okay however you'll
notice that MFA is not required for
local standard user access to cui when
the cuis on that user's Machine by the
way we also do these videos in exactly
one take because I'm way too lazy to
actually start over again very
interesting that is just a small hint of
where mfa's requirements may be easier
to implement than you think all right
I'm gonna go back over that again
because in all of my little bantering
there was actually an important point in
there so again if you're a standard user
non-admin and if you have cui only
locally on your computer and you can't
access that via you know some other
method over a network like a map network
drive from your computer which would be
unusual sort of uh then you don't
actually have to have MFA to get into
the local computer if you're a standard
user not an admin user okay so there is
this loophole from for basically
standard users on the network where they
don't actually have to have MFA to sign
in their computer a lot of people miss
that all right your buddy Mike this guy
okay hooking you up trying to make life
a little bit easier at least all right
let's jump into what the assessors are
looking for on this one and try to not
hit any potholes
now four things they're assessing for
one determine if privileged accounts are
identified that's pretty easy right of
course they're identified you look at
active directory and boom there's a you
know uh people in the admin Security
Group and people not in the admin
Security Group as an example all right
session Point number two determine if
multi-factor authentication is
implemented for local access to
privileged accounts so again if you're
an administrator okay and if the system
you're logging into has cui you must
have MFA implemented for all accounts
able to access cui all right pretty
straightforward determine if
multi-factor authentication is
implemented for network access to
privileged accounts okay now we're going
over a network to a privileged account
okay MFA is implemented for all accounts
able to access cui would be a really
great answer if you have it or MFA is
enabled on all accounts which have
network access to cui that'd be another
good answer both those are acceptable
now final final assessment point in
terms multi-factor authentication
implant for network access to
non-probo's accounts so if you're on a
network let's say you're in a domain
you've got your computer you got a
server the server's got cui on it you're
going to need MFA in order to open up
that map network drive so you can either
do it that way you can do MFA on sign
into the computer whatever you want to
do but MFA has to be somewhere in the
equation before you touch cui if it's
over the network note that they are not
assessing whether you have MFA on your
local machine or not that's not an
assessment point because that's not
right again you can have cui on your
local device you can do that you can
physically secure that device which is
the alternative to MFA but if it's okay
what over the network or it's a
privileged account you got to have MFA
if you're scratching your head
if you're scratching something else
and
you're trying to figure out what am I
going to do
it's not a multi-factor authentication
on my network seems like a
head scratcher a giant burden maybe
something really tough to do here's the
good news uh an on-call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this D fars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their
lapsed like a seal on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminate any gaps gray areas
and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliance
is your secret weapon to land more
Defense work with higher profit margins
now that is what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you
and if you want more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you all right visit
cmmccompliancecrets.com or check out the
bio below for links to get help right
now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you or my
incredibly disgusting burps help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance help
as soon as our compliances roll it out
until the next compliance tip my friends
stay safe and secure out there and hit
us in the comments below to let us know
what you'd like to know more about when
it comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you